oh thank an exclusive you like can we
live on a my man style fees bus right
now what's good man boom the hardest op
narrow the ghost baby no was good oh
yeah you just there offstage um first
things first I gotta give you props cuz
you went out to the crowd yeah you did
your thing you were in the crowd for a
minute and I'm go school it was hot
wasn't it yeah are you / for you did bmf
it out the end of the crowd man on the
time it was a good time man so how is
this currency Torben been treating man
it's good i can't complain like is real
good um good to see the next generation
donors my kids right yeah a lot of kids
Papa currency yeah definitely good to
see the next generation Estonian divas
II just what's out there hey honestly
you're gonna you want the other I would
necessarily call you a pioneer but you
are one of the first artists when I was
in high school I was regularly driving
make tapes yeah and it currency is it's
kind of like that's you know is he's a
mixtape heavy artist was kind of like
they're the new generation in the old
generation and and you're a pothead
rapper kinda and did I the hardest
[__] out hey you know so um how
did you you a courtesy link up cuz I
know um site or mommy blog okay before
daddy got eaten out
che SI la la remix support disappointed
either on a show for my brother I was
now headed after the charger stood at
the extra show me smoking knocked out
their first one he
one day pothead politician marijuana
marijuana is like such a it bonds so
many people it's creating art is if you
oh you know you come from a generation
of smokers and [__] and it's just how it
is Oh as far as you being a veteran OG
in the game you got a reporter front all
these kids every night there might not
be as you know up on your [__] if they
should be because you know they're
probably like 15 years yeah it shouldn't
be tion big what do you not from the
general is the reception bit it was
great tonight I've been a great it's
been great you some shows the first
years old I was like whoa yeah it was a
lie crayola yeah funny the first two
shows like real eye-openers good indeed
like you're on our hands but it's been
great I can't rely can't complain even
on me indie rock they go hard go hard on
me there's just it's surprising for me
to be a whole gene or schooling again
just a just a going different spots and
I'm not used to going soon right it
seemed seeing kids just on a hole on the
whole novel on a whole nother wave like
yeah that's still hip hop but you know
the saying this they just want any wave
cuz I off my currency to being a lane of
zone he is useless Johnny got his own
stop rapping wise is the roots like he's
got his own style here he's definitely
kind of carved that that's better that
kool following lane you know they're
saying his fans are crazy on something I
have to ask him in a big d black fan
everyone's been waiting on locks out
you try everybody and then you know you
got to understand when we came in the
last I was 15 years I now control the
paperwork right you know i mean so
that's one contract we don't control
okay we don't have to drop the d-block
album yes so you know those are things
we control of right as locks we just
artists this one label so it's not
really a few seconds go over the line
control over them no we don't have
control over dropping on the label okay
oh I got you right so that's okay with
allies that's been the hold up yeah
basically my you notice any but
hopefully to get right but it's always
service [__] that just keep popping up
as a lot of linguistics yeah I hear
that's that's what everyone's doing it
for four years man for years on you
dropped the album last year dope album
um since you started off at Interscope a
gangster and a gentleman time is money
was like the most delayed album ever I
member i was waiting for that our house
I'm really i was in jail it was in
general okay i just remember i just
remember i was waiting for the edge yeah
i mean if you get definitely delayed the
[__] its way the god-awful baby yeah
um what is the difference now that
you're kind of doing the indie thing I
mean you kind of scene all facets of of
the label situations were bad where you
were all Interscope home yeah he's doing
what you want right and you learn the
game you do what you want you to do what
works for you I think I have wisened up
over the time to say you know if I do
album i do it one and done no side
they'll do what I basically do what I
want to do what fits for me what's
comfortable for me you know um like I'm
walking to so I wrote an investor yeah
yeah
novel kiss you a little about it let's
see that for the right one thing out you
know you wrote this did you have helped
riding in wrote the whole thing okay top
above top to bottom and they could get
this online yeah you're done at barnes
and nobles or was it was dumb we're
gonna stop I'm not gonna tell you go two
styles p dinette and ritu chaplains for
free on your own what is what is I
Melissa Melissa background on the book
what's it about me said action-packed
jail mr. you gonna stop speeding on that
check it out whole industry two cellos
Cesar and adding a grabby way yeah what
expired I mean of course your liver sis
you're a writer I love words so so
that's what inspired because I mean I
always feel like this um you know a
certain level of creativity that has
today especially AMC like himself was so
dope has to have it did it translate
easily to write a book noise music
definitely was not here when I say how
long did this take you we went about a
year and a half maybe I was doing a lot
of albums yeah Eagles far as I post up
sunsets are kinda second sweet man I
gotta check this out but I didn't see
things your you wrote a book see I wrote
a booking in the other guy Long Knives a
total fiction novel don't know what
about my life that's why I'm without
hip-hop mine ain't about a lot is a
total fiction stories out man read for
enjoyment and its Tower malice drop the
book I like theater here so hey then
that's that's a good look so make sure
I'll get this so um stops be dinette on
any bookstore barnes and nobles
amazon.com borders indeed you know when
I was a primer favorite tape of yours
the goats in a show truck oh and then
you know recently dropped it was just
saying he dropped out first was it the
first 28 yeah I drop the first when you
spit a was fitter uh-huh the mixtape
game is a ball so much it's uh you were
like really really you and kisses she
really running the deck that Lane 40 it
was like Colin dipset running the mixed
a game for very long time um its
progress man's 2012 every was you know
the Internet is is everyone it's so
crazy how Raptors know what the
different way um how have you like how
to just adjust it to that cuz you've
kind of you know you've always been a
horror mixtape art as far as had a very
big mix a presence but nowadays it's
kind of like you don't have that you're
nothing it's just the way that you know
have you adjusted in the last few years
but now music has changed I've been with
the [__] I one should I keep it I keep
it g ro i'm not you know i think i've
been here since 95 yeah yeah you know I
mean I think what keeps me is good boss
I knew by that I live by making sure the
liver boss every single time to duel and
you do oh and I make sure the love and
um so far as with the group to my
partner's kiss she ride home kiss just
rock assignment you just drop the
consignment tape see what a smooth rider
that brings out now see what is the one
day one day
so you know I think it comes to a point
where you just do what you do for your
love of the heart it's gotta be that's
gotta be a for someone who's been
through the label you know carousel
that's got to be awesome to not have to
get [__] by go I'm just a go for all
right that's a that's gotta be a great
Nile to make your money like I like for
me personally like four styles while you
speak for novartis I'm different from
everybody like one day you might have me
gonna wanna wreck it with what you say
is a conscience backpack rapper right I
could also fit in and with with the game
wrong [__] gangster lay here you know
what I can pretty much go any length I
come here to flows better yeah you don't
understand the first 28 yo those hardest
hit like here you go drop a joint with
statik selektah terminology and then you
could do the joint across and then I'm
well-rounded so I wrapped a wrap you
stay to say I MC to MC so with that
saying I don't think I'm on my swag I
don't think about the numbers own thing
I think about boss about the other day
that's a play I let let the work that
the work speak for itself and I've been
here for a long time and as you see you
know it works out I think when you
respect your crap it's like a um so to
say our own
mixed martial arts master master dog yes
sir sure you don't look at him like you
know once you master yard and you do it
and you really focus on and on it those
who come up under your respect you and
you expect those who are under you know
knows who came before you cut you
respect the art in general and I think
when you get to that point it keeps you
around NZ um I always always look at
guys like yourself as I was always
thinking under regular 100 rate of
rapper I think sometimes you do that you
deserve sometimes like when people said
song about the hottest mcs are the best
em season do you ever feel like you
don't get the props that you deserve
that you might be other way if you ever
feeling not really because everybody
else feels I'm on nobody seems like you
are if you might be underrated but the
[__] that people think are hot
[__] with you so it's like I'm good
you're good so I'm good like you know I
think I think that comes with Raiders
come with when you choose to be rated
right you want to be ready I'm not
trying to be the hottest right now I'm
trying to have a you know I believe in
longevity right so I don't think I'm
underrated for one thing everybody knows
the [__] I'm talking about yeah my [__]
ain't ABC today you gotta really sit
down a thing you got to be some way
different money for the no I'm not for
the know like I don't really wrap for
the norm I don't rap to appeal to the
masses no and I think if I you know how
could I cry about not appealing to most
of the masses and be a commercial when I
don't wrap an MC like bless you like I'm
not sow like when it comes to gangster
rap there's probably like four or five
people like you can count on the hand
that you're included with one
like the hardest [__] I'm the hardest
and cranberry yeah and you know hardest
out I title don't change and I think
about everybody else you've debated over
who's the king who's the flyers whose
wedding artists who the artist is it you
might have a little debate hair in there
but my title pretty much sticks what's
next another album doesn't make say I
will mix tape I'm gonna drop a mixtape
like sure what you had you have to
they're like some world's most hard-ass
embassy let's go yeah okay the world's
most artists I'm seated okay Jane um
I'll let you know in a minute okay as as
a fan I prefer no DJ mix tapes but as a
fav cuz ya'll me tell you this your
Styles P so you don't need no DJ to call
now I do a little bit of both so am i
right you know I do a little bit of both
so I make one with the vision and you've
also grab it or for sale a movie with no
DJ office so the hardest MC out Will's
moves towards more okay the world okay
that's gonna be crazy yeah this um
another thing I wanted to ask you man
you've like you said you've been in the
game since 95 we've been around big bear
around puff maze DMX I mean you've been
a part of some special hip-hop [__] man
Roughriders bad boy truly I mean your
guys d black one is crazy man and is
still continuing to be crazy
what is the most memorable part of your
career thus far boom when you like look
back what what is what was the most
important part like that whole journey
is not without all things MC every day
is important but if you ask me what's my
best the good times I think any time you
work with a legend and you know that you
got to be friendly is the time of big
because you got got a lot to pick up
from the game as an MC right I think it
what people know about big was he was a
dedicated hip-hop love away so he
respected go up I think it's just being
able to be around somebody like that and
learn to respect the art in the craft
and especially me you already come came
in respecting your authentic crap they
get to see someone else from successful
and on top and that was they formula to
made a lot of sense as a young kid from
yonkers first time you met big mammal do
you remember that the first meeting yet
I remember on puff pass since around
song here's a young [__] ill I'll
spit it I was like wow he have to be
that homeboy was humbling to see him
that humble like an under me big was a
classy do to me like I think it was a
zoo is a real class act point blank
period it's hard to find people like
that in life point blank period
especially with with talent at that
magnitude and then I'll be able to get
him he was he was even be able to man to
be able to have be humble half-human and
he was trying to run yeah he was easily
was a class act right comes for
something oh hey i'm looking forward to
the mixtape it's gonna be sick make sure
you get that assignment if you ever in
New York tool please make sure you stop
by juices for life 1026 have new york
city if you can't stop by juices for
life go to sears best of all would ever
get your own blend to get your own
fruits may juice at home juice up you
did the juice thing no down on the juice
box and healthy life I gotta get on that
man without that's what it is man you
got the henny and the juice hahaha baby
baby